Hi, welcome back. In this session, we're
going to start on our discussion of
value investing.
Now, if you ask most investors how they
would classify themselves, many
investors call themselves value
investors. But as you will see in this
and the next few sessions, it's easy to
call yourself a value investor. It's
actually much more difficult to behave
like a true value investor. So, let's
set the ball rolling by first defining
who a value investor is. The lazy
definition is value investors invest in
stocks that rate at low PE ratios or low
multiples of book value. That's an
incredibly lazy definition. There are
lots of people who buy low PE stocks or
would not think about as value
investors. There's a slightly broader
definition which is that a value
investor cares about value.
But then does don't growth investors
care about value? Again, it seems to be
very selective in its use of the word
value. So, I'm going to start this
discussion by giving you my definition
of what a value investor is as
contrasted with a growth investor.
Earlier in this class, I introduced this
notion of a financial balance sheet. In
a financial balance sheet, I look at a
business and look at where it gets its
value. And I argued that your value as a
company, as a business, can come from
investments you've already made in the
past. Assets in place and investments I
expect you to make in the future. How
far in as far as the I can see called
growth assets.
And there are only two ways I said you
could fund this business. Either borrow
the money, use your own money. To me,
value investors are focused on getting
their value back from assets in place.
They invest in companies that get the
bulk of their value from assets in
place. Put simply, value investors look
at growth assets skeptically. They say
it's all in the future. It's based on
speculation.
Therefore, I'm not going to invest in
it. Value investing focuses on assets in
place. And the argument is they're
better position. Value investors are
better positioned in assessing the value
of assets in place and buying companies
that trade at less than the value of
assets in place.
This view of the world good or bad is
going to have consequences. We'll talk
about what kinds of companies will come
through as cheap with a in a value
investing focus of the world but it's
based on investments you've already
made. Now with that lead in there are
three ways in which value investing is
practiced. One is what I call passive
screening. What do you do in passive
screening? You look for companies that
have specific characteristic that make
it more likely that they're undervalued.
I'm going to show you the Ben Graham
screens which kind of know got the ball
rolling and those screens came out
decades ago and in those screens you're
essentially looking for companies that
you think are cheap. The second group of
value investing is built around
contrarian investing where the argument
is you're more likely to find something
to be undervalued after a big shock to
the system. What kind of shock? A bad
earnings report causing the price to
drop by 30, 40 or 50%. So contrarian
investors look for companies which have
been badly pummeled by markets looking
for bargains. Companies where the prices
are down but don't deserve to be as down
as they are. And the third group of
value investors I call activist value
investors. What do activist value
investors do? They spot companies that
they think could be more valuable but
only if they change the way they're run.
And here's what activist value investors
do to follow up. They take a position of
the company but they don't sit back and
wait for the stock price to adjust. They
put pressure on the company to change.
Of course that requires a whole set of
characteristic that those activist
investors have to bring to the table and
we'll talk about those passive
screeners, contrarian value investors,
activist value investors.
Now we'll talk more about screening in
the next session but I'm going to go
back and show you Ben Graham's original
screens. And this came from a very early
edition of his book, Intelligent
Investor, in the 19 1940s and 50s. Well,
here's what he looked for in a cheap
stock. He said the price earnings ratio
of the stock has to be less that the
inverse of the yield on a AAA corporate
bond. You're saying what? Let's say the
yield on a AAA corporate bond. AAA
corporate bonds are among the safest
corporate bonds is 5%.
The inverse of that yield is 20. You're
looking for a stock with a P ratio less
than 20. So you're bringing in both
interest rates and the level of the PE.
Second, to make sure you're not
capturing some aberration, the PE of the
stock has to be less than that company's
average PE over the last 5 years. You're
looking for a stock where the PE has
dropped. Low P where the PE has dropped.
Third, the Ben Graham approach was
heavily dependent on dividends. So the
dividend yield, the cash you would
collect each year would have to be at
greater than 2/3 of the AAA corporate
bond yield. Remember the corporate bond
yield of 5% your dividend yield would
have to be 3.33%
for the stock to passm low PE down more
than 60% over the average over the last
5 years. Dividend yield almost 2/3 or
more of the corporate bond yield.
fourth C and remember all these screens
would have to be melted. Your price
would have to be less than 2/ird of book
value. So the stock would have to be
trading at well below book value
and to pile on it has to be less than
2/3 of net current assets.
Net current assets would be you know net
of whatever items you want to take out
of it that you don't think you can
collect.
In addition to prevent risky stocks from
showing up, Ben Graham added a debt to
equity ratio being less than money based
on book value. Ben Graham's approach is
very heavily depend on accounting
statements and accounting numbers. The
current assets would have to be greater
than twice of current liabilities. So
you would not have a company where
accounts payable could get you into
trouble. The debt, so there's an added
debt screen, would have to be less than
twice net current assets. So 6, 7 and 8
ensure the company does not have either
debt in the conventional form accounts
payable that could get the company into
trouble. So you have a cheap stock
that's down a lot, pays a big dividend,
trades at less than book value, has very
little debt.
The last two screens bring in earning
screens. First is you want earnings that
are growing more than 7%.
a year and no more than two years of
negative earnings in the last 10 years.
What chance do you think there is of any
company passing these screens? I
yesterday I took the entire global
equity market put all 10 screens and not
one company in the world passed all 10
screens. You think why come up with
these unrealistic screens? Maybe in 1945
or 50 or 55 where book value actually
meant a very different thing than book
value today these screens worked and
that's something to remember screens are
creatures of the time that they created
in
that time maybe these screens yielded 20
or 25 companies and Ben Graham's
argument is these are truly undervalued
companies which have growth
and low risk going for them and you
should buy them. We'll come back and
look at more screens. But there have
been studies that have looked at Graham
screens. And um you know, but but before
we look at th those studies, it's well
worth noting that Ben Graham's legend
comes from as much from what he wrote,
security analysis and intelligent
investor as it does from his students at
Columbia University where he taught a
class on investing and valuation. And
among the students were Warren was War
Warren Buffett perhaps his most famous
student. I don't know whether Charlie
Manga was a student but Warren Buffett
definitely was and Warren Buffett and
Charlie Manga shared a lot of the same
respect for Ben Graham's work. But there
were studies especially one by you know
Oenheimer that looked at the stocks that
passed the Ben Graham screen and noted
that they were going to return well in
excess of the market. Mark Halbert who
used to evaluate investment newsletters
also seem to suggest that you know
scream you know newsletters that were
built around Graham scream similar to
Graham screens did better than other
newsletters that's pretty weak source
neither of those study I mean the the
OPAN studies is notorious holes in it
the one attempt to actually run a mutual
fund using the Graham screens by James
Ray really failed to deliver on the
promised return so it's a mixed message
as to whether Graham screens could
actually have made money, but it's
clearly it clearly opened the door to
screening in general.
Now, of course, as I said, Ben Graham's
most famous student was Warren Buffett
and Warren Buffett's um you know, Warren
Buffett's history as an investor goes
back to the 1960s when he had a
partnership. Eventually though the
vehicle through which Ben Graham Warren
Buffett is invested is Bkshire Hathaway
a company that uh has an insurance
company in its middle GEICO uses
insurance capital to invest in publicly
traded companies and some private
business essentially it's a closed
mutual fund embedded in an insurance
company
run by the most famous fund manager of
all time Warren Buffett. Now, the legend
of Warren Buffett is based, of course,
on how well Bergkshire Hathaway has done
for its investors. If you'd invested a
$100 in Bergkshire Hathway in 1965, that
would be worth 5.5 million at the end of
2024. You don't even have to do a
comparison to the S&P 500, but if you
wanted to, you could see how much better
you'd have done as an investor if
instead of taking the the route of
investing in the S&P 500, you'd put all
your money in Burkshire Hathaway. This
is one of those cases where you can't
attribute to luck. The returns on
Bkshire Hathaway have been so
dramatically higher than the market that
they clearly beat the the the structure
of risk. This isn't just a lucky
investor. This is a really good
investor.
Now, if you take a look at what Warren
Buffett's tenants are, and there are
dozens of books you can read in Warren
Buffett and extract your own lessons.
Here's what Warren Buffett seems to look
for in companies in terms of business.
He wants a company that's simple and
understandable. As I go through these
characteristics, it's worth thinking
about what kinds of companies you'd have
missed as a consequence as well. Every
great strategy also has blind spots. You
have to think about those blind spots.
Simple and understandable. A consistent
operating history in terms of income and
profitability
and favorable long-term prospects. So
you want a good business that
potentially has growth potential. In
terms of management, Buffett was big on
picking good managers, managers who are
honest and candid leaders rather than
followers. In terms of financial
tenants, he wanted businesses that
delivered a high return in equity, well
above the cost of equity, and high
stable margins. In fact, Buffett
concocted a version of earnings called
owner earnings where he added back
depreciation amotization and subtracted
capex. Kind of a midway point to free
cash flow equity that we talked about in
the valuation session.
And finally, in terms of market tenants,
he basically wanted to use conservative
estimates of earnings. In other words,
he didn't put in growth estimates just
because managers threw out there. He
used conservative estimates of earnings.
And this is one area where you might get
some push back. You said, you know, I
don't believe in betas or risk
adjusting. You know, I want to just beat
the riskless rate. In fact, I have often
got push back in my classes when I
adjust risk discount rates for risk
saying Warren Buffett doesn't adjust
discount rates for risk. Why are you
doing it? And my response is go back and
take a look at the certainty equivalent
version of a discounted cash flow
valuation. Get a sense? Go back to the
valuation session there. Instead of
adjusting the discount rate, you adjust
the cash flows for risk. By using
conservative estimates of earnings,
you're effectively taking that approach
and creating a pragmatic version of it.
Buffett's basic view is Mr. Market is is
is is bipolar, is capricious and moody,
and you're trying to take advantage of
that moodiness. Selling to Mr. Market
when he's over optimistic and buying
back when he's over pessimistic.
So the Buffett legend has a clear core
and for a long time that legend allowed
Bergkshire Hathaway to trade at a much
higher price relative to its book value
than other insurance companies. So in
this graph you say using you you can see
the price to book ratio for Burkshire
Hathaway and you can see that you know
over time the price to book ratio has
drifted down towards what other
insurance companies generate as price to
book. In fact between the last decade
the price to book ratio for Bkshire
Hathaway is getting pretty close to the
price to book ratio for insurance
companies. Put simply the buffet premium
seems to be fading. Why? One is H.
Right? When this graph started, Warren
Buffett was in his and Munger, Charlie
Mer. Basically, you have to think of
them as a pay were in their 60s. By the
time this graph is done, Warren Buffett
is 93 and Charlie Munger had passed on.
So, the Buffett premium has faded partly
because people know and Warren Buffett
has been open about it that Warren is no
longer the person picking the stocks at
Bergkshire Hathaway. He has his hands
selected, you know, managers doing it.
They might be very good managers in
terms of, you know, Ted Wexler and Todd
Combmes, but they're not Warren Buffett.
The Buffett premium has faded. That's
part of it. This, but there are other
forces that have also kind of reduced
the Buffett premium over time. In fact,
even if Buffett and Munger had not had
the aging issue, these would have
started to had started working in one is
the more people know what you do and the
more they imitate you, it might be a
source of it might might soo your ego,
but at the same time, the more people
imitate you, the less money you will
make on whatever strategy you adopt. And
that's definitely been true for Warren
Buffett. The second is a scaling
problem. When Warren Buffett started, he
ran a tiny fund. By the time you get to
the 1990s and this century, Burkshire
Hathway was one of the largest companies
in the world. You were investing
hundreds of billions of dollars. And
it's tough to scale up. It's tough to
earn the kinds of excess returns you do
when you have hundreds of billions
rather than a billion dollars or 10
million to invest. And the third is the
world has become much more macrodriven,
especially since 2008. What does that
mean? More of day-to-day movements in
stock prices are driven by macroeconomic
and market variables than company
specific variables. Put simply, you can
do everything right in picking a
company, but the world can shift under
you and you might not be able to make
money. Now, in fact, building on that
theme, as you embark on this mission to
be like Buffett, who doesn't, right? I
mean that look at that the the the
returns he was able to deliver. There
are three things I would like you to
keep in mind. First is you're operating
in a very different market than the
market that Warren Buffett entered in
the 1960s. In fact, um Warren Buffett
has been open in at the Burgkshire
Hathaway meetings in giving advice to
young investors starting out today
saying they'd be better off today
investing in an index fund than doing
what he did. Why? because there's so
much more data, so many more people
looking for bargains, the market's
changed. The second is
especially in the last 20 or 30 years,
some or a portion of Warren Buffett
success has come from the fact that he's
become an insider. What does that mean?
When he takes when Warren Buffett takes
a position at company, well, you know,
everybody knows he's taken a position.
The managers of the company actually
invite him in. of um you're the CEO of a
company where Warren Buffett has taken a
position in your company and you get a
call from Warren Buffett, I will wait.
You're going to take the call and when
he suggests that you should try
something different or do something
differently, you're going to take his
advice. So, it's become more there's an
activist component, not in the sense of
changing the management, but nudging
management to doing the right thing.
something that you and I will not be
able to do even if we replicate the
Buffett themes in terms of what we
invested. The third ingredient and this
I think is something worth thinking
about is patience. One reason Warren
Buffett was so successful is he was
willing to wait. Invest in a stock and
wait how long? As long as it took now
you're saying I'm patient, too. Well,
sometimes patience is not out in your
control, right? You're an equity mutual
fund manager. You're only as patient as
your least patient client. So what
allowed Warren Buffett to be as patient
as he was? One is the people who
invested with Warren Buffett trusted him
implicitly. They had such a high regard
for him that when he came back and said,
"Trust me, I know what I'm doing. Let's
wait a few years." You waited. There's a
selection bias. Most portfolio managers
don't have that luxury. And second, and
this is something that I think plays a
role in Buffett's success, is Warren
Buffett invested insurance company
money. You're saying, "So what?"
Insurance company money, you collect
premiums from people and your payouts
are based on the actuarial tables. The
actuarial tables don't panic.
In November 2008, at the peak of the of
that financial crisis, I remember
Buffett taking a position in Goldman
Sachs. At that time, nobody wanted to
buy an investment banking stock after
seeing what happened at Lehman.
Warren Buffett took a position. He got a
great deal because Goldman Sachs wanted
him as a shareholder. That goes with
being an insider. But he was able to do
it because he said, "Look, I can wait.
The actual tables don't panic. I don't
need the money right away." So if you
decide to be like Buffett, it's not as
easy as it looks in the book just
investing like he does. And I'm not sure
replicating what Buffett did will
deliver the kind of returns today that
it did for Buffett in the 1960s7s and
80s.
doesn't mean you shouldn't try but as
you read about the sage of Omaha and the
books and people read the bookway I know
I I admire Buffett because he's got this
core philosophy that he goes back to I
mean his strategies have shifted over
time but he's he's clear about what he
believes but it's worth remembering that
his philosophy was one built around
mature companies
and one and later we'll talk about one
of the limit of traditional value
investing, at least has practiced the
Buffett way, is you're going to not have
too many growth companies in. In fact,
Buffett is open about the fact that one
of his great regrets is not buying
Microsoft, even though he was best
friends with Bill Gates, or not holding
tech companies when they were growing
and young. So, the sage of Omaha,
amazing investor. The people who tracked
what Warren Buffett did, I'm not so sure
that they were able to replicate his
success. In fact, u I would wager that
if you take the crowds of value
investors who show up in Omaha every
year and you look at their track records
over the decades that they've been
investing using the Buffett approach
outside of their Bshire Hathaway
investment which is Buffett's you're
living in reflected glory. I'll wait the
rest of their investments have been
pretty average.
It's easy
to behave like Buffett and replicate his
actions. It's difficult to have his
staying power and his patience and it's
even more difficult to deliver the kinds
of returns that he did. So we'll talk
more about value investing as we go
along. But in this session I just wanted
to introduce you to those two leading
lights Ben Graham and Warren Buffer who
drive so much of traditional value
investing thinking. I hope you found
this session useful and I thank you very
much for listening.